>> Tucker: FBI INFORMANT
SAYS THAT RUSSIA SPENT
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ATTEMPTING TO INFLUENCE THE
CLINTONS.
DOUGLAS CAMPBELL HAS BEEN
SUPPLYING THE FBI WITH
INFORMATION SINCE 2009.
HE SAYS THERE IS AN
SECURE APPROVAL OF THAT
FAMOUS URANIUM DEAL.
NOW IN TESTIMONY TO THREE
SEPARATE CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEES, CAMPBELL SAYS
RUSSIA, THE GOVERNMENT,
SPENT MILLIONS TO THE
LOBBYING FIRM APCO WORLDWIDE
IN WASHINGTON TO ASSIST THE
CLINTON GLOBAL INITIATIVE.
THEY DID THIS IN THE HOPES
THAT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WOULD THEN
TREAT RUSSIA FAVORABLY ON
THE DEAL.
PETER SCHWEIZER IS THE
AUTHOR OF "CLINTON CASH."
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
SO, PETER, HOW -- I MEAN,
THIS SEEMS LIKE A BIG STORY.
DOESN'T MEAN IT WILL BE
COVERED BY ANYBODY BUT US
TOMORROW.
BUT THIS MAN AT THE CENTER
OF IT, CAMPBELL, CAN YOU
EXPLAIN HIS ROLE IN THIS?
>> SURE.
SO CAMPBELL IS A VERY
INTERESTING GUY.
HE HAS A HISTORY THAT HINTS
INTELLIGENCE.
BUT, HE FOUND HIMSELF IN THE
MID 2,000S AT BASICALLY
SERVING IN THIS CAPACITY
WITH TENNEX RUSSIAN FIRM
CONSULTANT PAYING $50,000 A
MONTH TO HELP THINGS
HAPPENING IN WASHINGTON,
D.C. AS A CONSULTANT.
HE SAW WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
HE BECAME AN INFORMANT FOR
THE FBI AND STARTED SHARING
INFORMATION.
AND WHAT HE IS SAYING IS
THAT, YOU KNOW, IN THIS
2009-2010 PERIOD, WHEN
URANIUM ONE WAS BEING
CONSIDERED AND FINALLY
APPROVED BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, THAT THE
RUSSIANS WERE FUNNELING
TO HELP THAT HAPPEN AND TO
BENEFIT HILLARY CLINTON.
AND HE SAYS HE TOLD THE FBI
ABOUT THIS BACK IN 2010, AND
THEY BASICALLY TRIED TO BURY
IT EVER SINCE.
>> Tucker: INTERESTING.
WHAT'S SO STRIKING ABOUT
THIS STORY THE RUSSIANS WERE
SO CONCERNED THAT THIS DEAL
WOULDN'T GO THROUGH.
YET, WE HAVE BEEN ASSURED BY
EVERYONE IN WASHINGTON, THE
THE LEFT BUT ALL SORTS OF
RESPONSIBLE PEOPLE OH, IT
WAS NO BIG DEAL.
IT WAS AUTHORIZED BY ALL
THESE DIFFERENT AGENCIES.
IT WAS NOT CONTROVERSIAL.
BUT IT WAS CONTROVERSIAL.
THERE WERE PEOPLE WHO
RUSSIAN COMPANY, WEREN'T
THERE.
>> OH, THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
TAKE CONGRESSMAN KING FROM
LONG ISLAND.
HE WAS THE RANKING MEMBER ON
THE HOMELAND SECURITY
COMMITTEE.
HE IS NOT A BOMB THROWER BY
ANY MEANS.
HE WAS OPPOSED TO THIS DEAL.
THE RANKING REPUBLICAN ON
THIS DEAL.
SENATOR BARRASSO OF WYOMING
WAS OPPOSED TO THIS DEAL.
ALL RAISING LEGITIMATE
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS ABOUT
DEAL OUTSIDE THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION BUT WITHIN
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION,
THERE WAS VERY LITTLE DEBATE
AND RAMMED THROUGH RATHER
QUICKLY.
>> Tucker: SO WE -- AT THIS
POINT ARE WE CERTAIN AND I
DON'T WANT TO GET OVER OUR
SKIS AT ALL ON THIS.
ARE WE CERTAIN THAT THE
GOVERNMENT OF RUSSIA SPENT
MONEY IN ORDER TO LOBBY THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND
PERHAPS THE CLINTONS WHO WAS
SERVING AS SECRETARY OF
STATE AT THE TIME IN ORDER
TO SECURE THIS URANIUM DEAL?
WE KNOW THAT?
>> WELL, WHAT WE KNOW IS
THAT THE RUSSIANS GAVE MONEY
TO APCO, $3 MILLION.
THE RUSSIANS, ACCORDING TO
CAMPBELL IN AUDIO AND
VIDEOTAPES THAT THE FBI HAVE
SAY THAT IT WAS USED FOR THE
PURPOSES OF URANIUMNG
PURPOSES OF URANIUM ONE.
TUCKER, ALL THIS RUSSIAN
MONEY IS SLOSHING AROUND
WASHINGTON, D.C.
AND IT'S NOT A SURPRISE LOOT
OF PEOPLE MAKING MONEY AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE TRYING TO DO
BIDDING FOR MOSCOW WHETHER
IT WAS ON URANIUM ONE OR ON
THREAT YOU WOULD HAVE TO BE